today on the matt wall show horrific
tragedy strikes in texas as democrats
immediately exploit dead children to
score political points i have a lot to
say about all this and i'll say it today
also nancy pelosi finally responds to
the archbishop who banned her from
taking communion her response only
further demonstrates why she deserved
the ban and record turnout for the
georgia primaries yesterday does that
disprove the democrats voter suppression
narrative stacey abrams says no plus we
have some exciting and fascinating
space-related news whether you like it
or not you're going to hear about it and
for our daily cancellation what is a
super fat and in
infinifat
you'll find out today all that and much
more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just like the foundation of this great
country is the constitution the
foundation of your family should be your
faith and your beliefs so i have a
serious question for you if something
should happen to you or your spouse who
do you trust to instill those same core
beliefs and values in your children do
you think it's the same person the state
would assign them to probably not if you
don't have a will in place you have no
say over the future of your children and
if you're single and you don't think you
need a will it couldn't be more wrong a
will allows you to establish advanced
directive and medical power of attorney
do you really want to leave the burden
of deciding life support or not to your
family members or your close friends
that's not a burden you should put on
anybody that's why a will allows you to
clearly communicate to your loved ones
what your wishes are regarding your
health
if you haven't made one yet you're not
alone but we're going to make it easy
epicwheel.com it's epicwheel.com when
you use promo code walsh we are so
excited that they're partnering with us
they are they're protecting our staff
and their families let them protect
yours too epicwill.com promo code walsh
this is how easy it is you can secure
your future in as little as five minutes
with a complete will package starting at
just 119 and when you use promo code
walsh you'll save 10 percent that's epic
will.com this will be the most important
five minutes you spend today
well all mass shootings are tragedies of
course especially school shootings but
an attack on an elementary school
reaches the deepest levels of demonic
depravity if you're a parent of
elementary school-aged children as i am
you can't help but imagine yourself in
the position that so many parents in
uvalde texas are in today and it's
enough to take your breath away
unthinkable unspeakable horrific
the body count last i saw is 21. that's
two adults and 19 kids mostly in second
third and fourth grade um
they were slaughtered by an 18 year old
piece of
human filth who walked into robb
elementary school yesterday barricaded
the doors
and walked into a classroom and started
just
killing everybody in the room
the ap is reporting that the shooter was
uh finally taken down by a heroic border
patrol agent who rushed into the
building without backup as they're
reporting it we can only hope that the
shooter
suffered before he died and uh went to
burn in hell for all eternity
an event as shocking and terrible as
this could be a moment of
unity for the nation it would be
fleeting of course it would not last
very long but at least for a time
however brief
you would hope that we could come
together in grief and mourning over
children whose lives were taken
and also the many more children whose
lives are now forever altered by the
horrors that
they witnessed it could be time for some
real soul-searching i mean actual
soul-searching as in searching our souls
to figure out
what the hell has gone so wrong in our
society
but a symptom of our peculiar national
soul sickness is that we don't have
moments like this and we certainly don't
engage don't engage in any real
introspection ever
our leaders helped to make sure of that
which is why president biden addressed
the nation in prime time last night
spent all of about two minutes
expressing his sorrow over the 19
murdered children and then launched into
a political stump speech about the gun
lobbying republicans and that's how he
spent the remainder of his remarks
listen
as a nation we have to ask when in god's
name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby when in god's name
we do we all know in our gut needs to be
done
it's been 340
3448 days
10 years since i stood up at
a high school in connecticut a grade
school in connecticut
where another government massacred 26
people including 20 first graders at
sandy hook elementary school
then
there have been over 900 incidents
of gunfire reported on school grounds
marjory stoneman douglas high school in
parkland florida
santa fe high school in texas
oxford high school in michigan
list goes on and on and the list grows
when it includes mass shootings at
places like movie theaters houses of
worship
as we saw just 10 days ago at a grocery
store in buffalo new york
i am sick and tired of it
we have to act
and don't tell me
we can't have an impact on this carnage
i spent my career as a senator and a
vice president
working to pass common sense gun laws
we can't it won't prevent every tragedy
but we know they work and the gun
manufacturers have spent two decades
aggressively marking assault weapons
which make them the most and largest
prophet
for god's sake we have to have the
courage to stand up to the industry
now words uh cannot express how
sickening that performance
was
instead of trying to unite the nation in
our grief biden chose politics the
bodies
hadn't even all been identified yet they
were still taking dna swabs from parents
so they could match them to the victims
and biden was already taking pot shots
at his favorite political targets
not to mention rambling off the cuff and
repeating himself as always we're being
led by an incoherent
incompetent fool who also happens to be
a very
very deeply bad man
of course the entire democratic party
and almost all the corporate media
has taken this same cue now the shooter
is hispanic attacking a predominantly
hispanic school so there's no useful
racial narrative for the vultures to
exploit and that means they go right to
gun control and that's been the story
since last night because they've decided
to make it the story this morning
michael moore was on msnbc ranting about
repealing the second amendment just like
repealing it outright
that's how far they'll go in exploiting
tragedy
but just as they are standing on the
bodies of dead children to make their
political points they're also stepping
over the facts ignoring them completely
because the fact of the matter is that
none of the recent mass shootings would
have been prevented by any of the quote
unquote common sense gun control
regulations democrats like biden are
proposing
none of them
another fact is that these shootings
happen everywhere
regardless of the law as much as the
left likes to pretend that the gun laws
are the same everywhere in the country
that's not the case many states and
cities already have strict gun laws
other places have more relaxed laws if
the law is to blame here then we should
observe that all of the shootings are
happening in places with relaxed laws
but that's not what we observe
in fact the majority of gun violence
happens in blue states and blue cities
with strict laws
texas of course has has more respect for
the second amendment than almost any
other state in the union yet the shooter
in yuvaldi
still had to break myriad laws to commit
the horrific crime that he committed
would a few more laws have made a
difference which laws
exactly would have made a difference red
flag laws well they have those up in up
in new york
yet a shooter with a history of violence
and making threats exactly the kind of
guy that red flag laws are supposed to
stop
still manage to slaughter people at a
grocery store
they've got gun control and red flag
laws in new york and it still happened
so what laws then
law is supposedly limiting the types of
guns available for purchase
well even if you can stop people from
buying whatever type of gun you ban
you can't stop them from modifying the
legal guns to make them function more
like the banned ones which is precisely
what many mass shooters including the
one in buffalo do
also a shooter with a simple handgun and
enough ammo can can inflict horrendous
carnage if he's attacking defenseless
people in a gun-free zone
the type of gun just doesn't seem to
matter all that much
you could take away every gun
and that still wouldn't stop the attacks
the terrorists in waukesha just used his
car instead of a gun the worst school
attack in u.s history happened in 1927
45 people died
not one gun was fired
because the killer used explosives
so what laws
what law will stop this
universal background checks
that's what nba coach steve kerr called
for last night in the wake of the
shooting listen to this
are we going to do something
i'm tired i'm so tired of getting up
here and offering condolences to
to the
devastating families that are out there
i'm so tired of the excuse i'm sorry i'm
tired of the moments of silence
enough
there's 50 senators
right now who refuse to vote on hra
which is a background check rule that
house passed a couple years ago it's
been sitting there for two years
and there's a reason they won't vote on
it to hold on to power
so i ask you mitch mcconnell i ask all
of you senators you refuse to do
anything about the violence in school
shootings and supermarket shootings i
asked you
are you going to put your own
desire for power ahead of the lives
of our children
how will
background checks
stop someone without a criminal record
from purchasing a
firearm how
now there's no indication as far as we
know that the shooter in texas had a
criminal record
you know very often mass shooters have
no history of crime up until the moment
when they decide to murder dozens of
people but a background check isn't
going to tell you what people are going
to do in the future
okay it's not a future check it's a
background check
and if there's no criminal history
there's nothing in the background then
what is it supposed to do what does it
achieve
on the other hand gun violence in our
cities the sort of violence that kills
the most people in this country every
year hands down
is often carried out by people with
criminal records sure but they don't
purchase their guns legally
so there's no law that could make their
possession and use of a firearm any more
illegal than it already is so again what
law would stop this
now i'm not arguing that there's nothing
at all we can do
i'm not saying that
there are some things one thing in
particular would be a good starting
point put armed and trained security in
every school in america
armed and trained security in every
school in america
we have the budget for it we could send
40 billion dollars to ukraine you're
telling me we don't have the money to
put security in our own schools for our
own kids
we got billions of dollars apparently
laying around we could just send it off
to not just ukraine we're shipping money
to
dozens and dozens of countries all
across the world
now we could worry about securing
ukraine
with 40 billion dollars how far would 40
billion dollars go in how many schools
in america could we fully and completely
protect
with armed and trained security with 40
billion dollars
now this is not a foolproof plan nothing
is but it's it's a it's a whole lot
better than having no security
now it's not clear as far as i'm aware
if the school in texas had security or
what sort of security it had if any but
regardless there was an armed good guy
on the scene very quickly
20 children were still killed
it would have been even worse a lot
worse
if the good guy with the gun had not
been there or had arrived five minutes
later even
obviously our kids are safer in school
if the schools are secured
obviously
we have armed security at airports we
have them at stadiums for football games
we have armed security in in most
government buildings congress has armed
security the president has armed
security if you go to the dmv or the
social security office you'll find at
least one armed security guard there to
protect and defend what documents
license plates
we have armed security to protect
everything we deem important and even
some things that don't seem all that
important and yet there are people who
don't want our kids to be protected it's
mind-boggling
we just heard from steve curry he's
pounding on the table with tears in his
eyes calling for someone to do something
do something he's shouting
in this uh theatrical performance and i
do call it that i'm sorry i don't take a
tear seriously i don't think they're
genuine
and i'll tell you why because two years
ago kerr joined in protesting against
armed police officers at school in
oakland
so he's in tears over kids getting shot
and killed yet he doesn't want security
in those schools what
he wants someone to do something unless
that something involves actually
actively protecting our children let me
ask you steve kerr okay if an if a if a
guy with a gun
is going to a school to kill kids is it
better for there to be security guards
on campus or not are you going to
suggest it's actually better if there's
nobody there
that is insane that doesn't make any
sense
so what's the argument against it
and whatever your stupid argument
against securing the schools and
protecting our children is why do you
never make the same argument in relation
to any of the other buildings that are
guarded 24 7 by security are congressmen
more important than our kids there was
one riots
where a bunch of unarmed yahoos invaded
the capitol building and they responded
by locking the whole city down for
months like fort knox and even now
they've got like armies of security
surrounding that building and it'll be
like that forever
but a decades-long string of massacres
at school including two of the deadliest
at elementary schools and that's still
not enough to get everybody on board and
agreeing that schools need security
like everything else we can argue about
but how is that not the first thing we
do
do the people opposing such efforts
actually want kids to die
so they can use their deaths for
political gain do they actually want our
kids to be sitting ducks
i don't want to think that anyone would
think that way but i cannot fathom any
other explanation
well this brings us to a final point uh
though certainly not the least important
point
speaking of that decades-long string of
massacres
why
why is this happening
you know this is yet another reason why
the gun control narrative falls apart
americans have owned guns since forever
since the second amendment was ratified
since before that and yet these kinds of
attacks seem to be far more common now
than they were in the past now you can
look in the statistics and oftentimes
people will do that and they'll try to
debunk and they'll say well no
technically you know schools weren't any
safer in the 90s than they are now and
everything
and and
you know if you if you look at violence
in general and everything and you
average it all out there may be some
truth to that but also you know it's
like we're not imagining things right i
mean i can remember
going to school myself in the 90s and
there were
there was the one big incident that we
all remember columbine and the reason
why we all remember that 20-plus years
later is because at the time when it
happened it was
unimaginable it's like
unheard of
and it's just it's not unheard of
anymore
so it certainly seems like these sorts
of things are happening
much more often than they used to
i mean talk to your parents depending on
how old you are i talked to my parents
when they they went to school you know
going to schools in the in the 60s
was it like every year there's a there's
a massacre at a school no
so so so why
like why is this happening
and
here's the question that we somehow
never ask which is the why
before we ask
how
a mass shooter got his hands on the gun
he used to commit his crime or even how
he was able to access the school grounds
in order to commit his crime shouldn't
we ask why he wanted to do that in the
first place
isn't that the first question why would
anyone
no matter how many guns he has available
to him
why would anyone want to do that
what's gone wrong inside his mind and
his soul
whatever plan you devise to prevent a
murderous demon from killing innocent
people it will be at best a band-aid i
fully admit that armed security at
school is a band-aid solution it's a
necessary band-aid it's a band-aid that
will save lives but it is a band-aid
it doesn't get to the core of the
problem
the core of the problem is that the
murderous demon exists
that he is a murderous demon in the
first place
that such a person was
produced
there is a terrible spiritual sickness
permeating our society
we seem to be producing a lot of these
kinds of people
evil has a deep foothold here we scratch
at the surface of the problem
we never look beneath
if ever we did we would find certain
themes emerging now i don't know
anything about this scumbag in texas
i i most of his backstory has yet to be
reported as far as i have seen but i can
predict certain biographical details
i can just predict this
he didn't have a stable home life
he spent most most of his life online
staring at screens isolated from other
flesh and blood humans
he almost certainly didn't have
any friends or very many
probably didn't have a girlfriend
he didn't have much or any moral or
spiritual formation he was empty
nihilistic despairing he had no purpose
or direction this is the case for almost
all of the mass shooters that's why i
can predict it
and if this was not the case for him
he's an outlier but it almost certainly
is
this is also the case by the way for
almost all the violent criminals in our
cities
all this applies to them too
this is what ties them all together see
it's not it's not a we like to think
that these are two completely different
kinds of things
all the violence in the cities people
are dying every single day
randomly shot to death on street corners
and then the mass shootings at schools
and in other uh places and we like well
these are two because they're not two
completely different categories of
things they're actually very similar
and this is the thing that ties them all
together
it's the actual source of the crisis
it's what makes it's what makes
the sorts of people who do these sorts
of things
the people who we try to contain or
control with laws
but no law in itself can make a man safe
if he is corrupt and evil to his core
you know if he's the kind of man who
would want to do something like this
he's never going to be safe
you're never going to be safe around him
the real solution is one that makes war
against that evil right
the evil down there at the core
and we are not serious about addressing
the problem
until we resolve to address that problem
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well with the summer basically here and
all the nice weather you don't want to
waste your time
wandering helplessly for hours around an
auto parts store you don't want that do
you and with all the ever increasing
number of car makes and models it's now
impossible to stock all the parts you
need in a traditional chain storefront
which means you can wander around and
not even find what you want all those
hours wasted you'll never get back why
endure often pointless or seemingly
intimidating questions about the
specifications of your vehicle only to
have the counterman
order the parts on his computer anyway
you have computers with access you don't
need any damned counterman you can just
go to rockauto.com yourself at home be
your own counterman uh and you got
rockauto.com in your home in your pocket
why would you choose to spend 30 50 100
more for the exact same auto parts at a
chain store or a new car dealership no
need for that rockauto.com is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they have
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's for your
classic or your daily driver get
everything you need and a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer amazing selection
reliable prices
no counter men rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
remember as always to write walsh in
their how did you hear about us box
so they know that i sent you
well nancy pelosi
has uh finally responded about uh being
banned from communion by her archbishop
her first response was reportedly to and
not surprisingly to just ignore him and
and she was told not to receive
communion but she was in dc and so she
went and received it anyway um
and uh but here she is on on msnbc
giving a a more uh
a longer i was gonna say more thoughtful
certainly not thoughtful at all a longer
anyway verbal response to this and let's
listen what's so sad about it and as
you're speaking i'm thinking of
some of the discussions i've had with
other members of congress over time and
what is important for women to know and
families to know that this is not just
about
terminating a pregnancy so these same
people are against contraception family
planning in vitro fertilization it's
it's a
it's a blanket thing and they use
abortion as the front man for it while
they try to undo so much that's what
they tried to do in the affordable care
act which didn't have anything about
terminating an abortion
a pregnancy so so let's just say that
uh i you know i wonder about death
penalty which i am opposed to so is the
church but they take no action against
people who may not share their view
thank you for referencing the gospel of
matthew which is sort of the agenda of
the church
that is rejected by many who
side with them on terminating a
pregnancy so we just have to be
prayerful we have to be respectful i
come from a
largely pro-life italian-american
catholic family so i i respect people's
views about uh about that but i don't
respect us voicing it on to others
uh she mentions the gospel of matthew
i'm glad that you brought that up
because uh there's another
very
unfortunately relevant
passage in the gospel matthew the entire
thing is actually quite relevant the
entire bible is quite relevant to
everything going on in our
in our lives um
but one passage particularly matthew 18
6
um
you know for anyone who harms one of
these little ones it would be better for
that person if a millstone
was hung around his neck and he was
tossed into the sea
so how about that from the gospel of
matthew nancy pelosi
i mean according to gospel matthew you
would be better off with a millstone
around your neck drowning in the sea
that's not me talking that's jesus
christ talking
tell me what part now i can point to
that in the gospel of matthew many other
parts
of it like the entire
gospel
that condemns
people who
harm children
so show me the part of the gospel
matthew that endorses it
can you show me
that show me show me the part go through
any i'll give you anything any of the
gospels actually find me the passage in
the gospels where jesus says something
that leads you to the conclusion
that he wants you to kill children
so when god
as we are told in in jeremiah forms uh a
child in the womb
you know he knows
the child from the moment that child is
stitched together in the womb
and then
stitches the child together forms the
child together in the womb of his mother
where is the indication in the bible
anywhere in the bible that god actually
wants you to kill
that living being that he formed in the
womb
can you find that i'd like to know
she mentions the death penalty and of
course she's uh she totally
misrepresents the situation there you
know the death penalty is actually but
that's another thing i'm glad that she
brought it up
because the death penalty is that's not
a clear cut she says oh the church is
against the death penalty uh no
historically the church is not against
the death penalty
in fact historically the church has been
in favor explicitly in favor of the
death penalty in certain circumstances
now
pope francis this most recent pope
doesn't like the death penalty and he
made some changes very recently to the
catechism which were quite controversial
to say the least
and there's a whole lot of debate about
what he put in there with regards to the
death penalty death penalty whether he
even had the authority to put it in
there and to phrase it the way that that
he did
talking about i don't remember the exact
phrasing but talking about the death
penalty like as if it's an intrinsic
evil
and he didn't say that and this is
always the case with pope francis this
is why
his this is one of the reasons why his
pontificate has been so damned uh
frustrating again an understatement
but he's just constantly confusing
everyone about everything like nothing
he says is clear so we're just sitting
right he'll say something or write
something everyone's sitting around
debating what the hell does that mean
because he's never clear about it
and so with his proclamations about the
death penalty so he didn't come out
directly and say it's an intrinsic evil
but he kind of indicated that but at the
same time you can't say that
because the church has
explicitly
in the past endorsed that kind of
penalty for certain crimes
so you're saying the church endorsed
intrinsic evil in the past well you
can't say that
so
with the death penalty i think where
this leads us is that um
it is at a minimum uh
a con controversial and people have come
down on either side of it
of the issue
with abortion that's not the case
there's zero controversy
it has been from the beginning forbidden
there's nobody
of any credibility or any real authority
on the other side of the issue
and that's one of the reasons for that
is that there's no coherent argument you
can actually make there's no coherent
argument on any level you can make in
favor of abortion there's certainly no
coherent moral argument you can make and
even more so if you're trying to make a
theological argument
there are plenty of theological
arguments you can make in favor of the
death penalty
including let's start with the fact that
god himself in the old testament
prescribes it i think god himself says
uh prescribes the death penalty for
certain crimes he does
so from and i get if you're not
religious if you don't believe in the
bible that doesn't mean anything to you
fine but we're talking this is a
religious conversation right now what
we're talking about nancy pelosi that's
she's making claims on on those grounds
all right um
georgia primaries yesterday brian kemp
was the uh clear victor there for uh
he'll be the republican candidate once
again for governor
and then stacey abrams will be the
democrat candidate and she's almost
certainly going to lose and the reason
because she's almost certainly going to
lose again
that's one of the reasons why she uh
passed the claim ahead of time that the
votes are rigged and that there's you
know and everything else
um and that
rigged it rigged in a different way
right she says it's rigged because we're
suppressing votes and we're keeping like
the people that would vote for her are
being kept home somehow
and she's making that claim just like
everybody on the left is especially
after georgia passed its election
integrity and voter id laws except that
here's the problem for her
that um for the primaries this yesterday
there was record turnout
we'd never seen anything like it in
georgia so this was after laws were
passed we're supposed to be suppressing
the vote and then you have record
turnout
well does that have the effect of kind
of disconfirming
her claim about votes being suppressed
she says no listen
the question about voter suppression and
voter turnout is causation without
correlation wean i'm sorry
you can make mistakes even when you know
what you're talking about it's
correlation without causation we know
that increased turnout has nothing to do
with suppressant
has nothing to do with it
suppressing by the way means that when
you're like you're stopping something
from happening you're you're
mitigating it minimizing it that's what
suppression
is and there's no correlation
so there's no correlation between
voter suppression and the number of
people who vote so
theoretically right
100 of eligible voters could vote and
she could still claim that they're being
suppressed
what
what
what do you mean then by suppressed if
everybody is voting
and it might not be everybody in georgia
but it's record numbers
uh more people voting after these
supposed voter suppression policies are
put in place
then what do you even mean when you say
suppression what what what are you
talking about
well the answer is that voter
suppression just like systemic racism
just like everything else you hear from
democrats it's a it's an unfalsifiable
theory
right there's nothing that can happen
that will have the effect of falsifying
it
nothing
no matter what happens climate change
another example unfalsifiable no matter
what happens it confirms
okay famously that's why they change it
from global warming to climate change
because it's like that makes it that
makes it by definition unfalsifiable
because any change in the climate
anything that happens in the climate it
confirms climate change because look at
that it's changing
systemic racism they say that america is
horribly systemically racist
it doesn't matter
what happens we cannot we can elect a
black president and that has no
um
bearing on systemic racism
because it's unfalsifiable
and one of the you know here's how you
know and by the way unfalsifiable theory
is uh is by its nature an invalid theory
okay that means it's just something
arbitrary it's something ad hoc it's
something you made up
um
it's like it's like trying to play a
game with little kids that like a game
that they've made up
if you've ever tried to play with with
with little kids some kind of game
they'll play this game with me and
they're just like making up the rules as
they go along
so it's impossible for you to win
and that's what the left does
no matter what happens they change the
rules they change the definitions
everything is uh unfalsifiable and you
know it's an unfalsifiable theory
because all you have to do is ask them
when it comes to systemic racism just
you know next time you're talking to
someone on the left about this say ask
them what what what do you what needs to
happen like what
needs to happen to prove to you
that there is no systemic racism against
black
people and the answer's gonna be nothing
and if nothing can disprove a theory
then that means that nothing has proven
it either
that means that this is a theory which
exists
entirely apart from evidence
and one of the reasons that they do this
is that they also want
they
nothing can ever get better right
because they always want to have the
victim claim
which means that they call themselves
progressives and they're they're
supposedly working towards some utopia
but you can you can never get there
there could never be any
improvement so even after we have a
black president
you know after that it's we'll hear from
the left that actually racism is worse
than it's ever been
not only has it not gotten better it's
actually worse
uh speaking of things being the worst
another highlight from abrams
who's uh again running for governor of
georgia
but
she has a very low opinion of georgia
let's hear that
i am tired of hearing about being the
best state in the country to do business
when we are the worst state in the
country to live when you're number 48
for mental health
when you're number one from maternal
mortality
when you have an incarceration rate
that's on the rise and wages that are on
the decline then you're not the number
one place to do to live
in the united states but we can get
there gwinnett
the worst place she wants to run for
vote for me this is the worst place ever
vote for me this is one of the reasons
why she's going to lose again and then
cry that she didn't really lose i mean
because she didn't lose the first time
she says she's governor right now
actually
uh the worst place to live
and one of the she says a ranking of 48
was at 48th and mental health
i don't know where she got actually
looked it up to say like where what
ranking are you basing this on
and how exactly do you rank mental
health what is
how do you rank the mental health of
everybody in a state
and then compare it to other states
that's totally meaningless
but um this is why
democrats are terrible leaders is
because they
hate you know you can't effectively lead
anything if you hate the thing you're
leading
right
you can't be an effective leader in an
institution if you hate the institution
if you work for a company and you hate
the company then you're going to be a
terrible manager if you're put in a
position of leadership
and even worse if you hate the people
also in the company if you hate the
people you're leading
which democrats do um then you're gonna
be a terrible leader
you have to have some kind of affection
for the institutions that you're leading
or you're not gonna be able to lead
effectively within those institutions
and for death this is why all these
cities are falling apart
that are led by democrats they hate
these cities and they hate everybody in
them
i want to move to this camilla harris is
um trying out a new version of the it
takes a village cliche
let's hear that
you know when we talk about our children
i know for this group we all believe
that when we talk about the children of
the community
they are a children of the community
the children of the community
are the children of the community
okay and what she means by that of
course is like they these are children
that belong
uh to the community
it takes a village or they're not just
your children they belong to everybody
but we know that that is
that is false we also know and we also
know when they say that when they say
community what they mean is the
government
that's always what they mean
that's why i would say they call it
public school i always that's why i
always say we it's government school
forget about public
be very clear about what is meant here
and that's what they mean always is the
government is in charge you know you
know one of the reasons why why that's
why that's not true
you know why they're my kids
and i'm going to be in charge of them
and i'm caring for them and i'm not
going to entrust them to the community
quote unquote
and i wouldn't even if by the community
you actually meant the community
i still wouldn't
entrust my children to the community
and there there are many reasons for
that
but one of the big ones
is that i love my kids and you don't
right the government doesn't love
my kids
even the community even if you live in
the the best community in the world
they're not going to love my kids at
least the way that i do they might in a
kind of a general if you're a generous
kind of person
and you're a good christian
you're going to have love for people
in the sense that you want what's best
for people in this kind of general sort
of way
in in a way of being a charitable kind
of a charitable love
but you're not going to love my kids
in the way that i do
you're not going to be
invested in their well-being as i am
um
has invested in making sure that not
only they are are safe but that they
grow into being good people
like i would die for that i would die
for my kids i would die to ensure that
they grow into good people that's that's
i would give my life to that and i am
and so is my wife
and that's the kind of investment i have
in my kids and that's why they're my
kids
you send them off to public school they
there's there's no love there they're
just they're a number
they're uh
a warm body in a chair right they're
just
they're kind of they're they become a
statistic
and the schools want to make sure that
as many graduate as possible because
it's better statistics they want to send
as many possible off to the uh off to
the university system because that's
better statistics and so everything is
it just becomes statistical statistical
reality my kids are not statistics to me
they're human beings they're my kids i
know them
you don't
and that's why i i am equipped to care
for them in a way that nobody else is
all
right okay one other thing here i want
to read before we
get to the comment section
and i'm going to read this
you're going to listen to it
whether you like it or not
this is from the daily wire it says
according to the national aeronautics
and space administration
something weird is going on in the
universe
you're just going to sit and listen to
this
nasa made the determination by examining
evidence gleaned from the hubble
space telescope deep in space which has
measured the speed at which the universe
is currently expanding which is much
faster than the speed of the expansion
of the big bang
nasa writes the cause of this
discrepancy remains a mystery but hubble
data encompassing a variety of cosmic
objects that serve as distance markers
support the idea that something weird is
going on possibly involving brand new
physics
this is actual this is the scientific
language from nasa something weird's
going something weird is going on here
that's scientific length but it is it's
interesting and that's why i'm going to
continue reading it
scientists had assumed that gravity
would slow down the universe's expansion
over time dr kathy romer of the dark
energy survey told the daily mail the
universe is not only expanding but it's
expanding faster and faster as time goes
by what we expect is that the expansion
will get slower and slower as time goes
by because it has been nearly 14 billion
years since the big bang
14 billion years okay it's a long time
that's an interesting length of time
i would even say
nasa explains when nasa conceived of a
large telescope in the 1970s one of the
primary justifications for the expense
an extraordinary technical effort was to
be able to resolve
um cepheids stars that brighten and dim
periodically seen inside our milky way
and external galaxies
using these stars discovered by
astronomer henrietta swan levitt in 1912
scientists measured distances in the
universe they then used exploding stars
called
type la supernovae to measure greater
distances using both approaches
scientists could estimate the hubble
constant named after scientist edwin
hubble a value that can estimate the age
of the universe by measuring the
expansion rate but some of these
calculations are breaking down to the
point and so they're just confused by it
right
this interesting fact about space that
i'm telling you
you go tell your friends about it
all right
we got through it together
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
cool papa j magic says i so appreciate
matt for sticking with the grooming
nonsense even when the news cycle keeps
moving this is the issue along with
abortion this is the hill to die on
uh yeah i i generally have disdain for
the news cycle you know i'm not gonna i
don't maybe you've probably noticed by
now
i don't this show is not ruled by the
news cycle
now
there can be things happening in the
news that everyone in the news is
talking about that actually
is worth talking about like such as
today
uh but generally speaking i don't make a
it's it's
i don't rely on the media to tell me
what's important and what i should talk
about on the show
just one correction though um
when you say this is the hill to die on
i agree in a sense but also you know i
ain't dying on this hill okay that's
they are figuratively
right this is this is uh that's my only
problem with this
uh is this the hill you're gonna die on
thing
and of course we know the people that
say that i i get accused of this all the
time i hear this from from from people
especially other conservatives are you
really going to die on this hills this
is the hill you're going to die on
and the people that say that
they never like whatever hill you're on
they say that's not worth dying for but
then they never find a hill worth dying
on as far as they're concerned they just
keep they keep uh surrendering hill
after hill after hill until there's no
hills left
and um yeah i think that there are
plenty of of these hills worth dying on
but i also don't plan on dying on the
hill i think and when it comes to the to
the grooming thing gender ideology you
know that particular hill
uh that's a hill we can actually win
so
let's see arthur says
before you do any serious business with
any company check and see if they have a
chief diversity officer i totally agree
with you
only caveat is that um i have been
pushing to be the chief diversity well
i'd like to be chief diversity officer
of the daily wire we don't have one but
that's a that's a position that i am
would very much like to take on
um and if not that i've also been
pushing to be chief diversity officer of
twitter if
elon musk takes over
so there are a couple exceptions to that
but generally i think you're right
rhys says on the issue of the jackie
robinson comparison i think it's not
just what is said but also how it's said
asians are a protected class now go call
one of them jackie chan it would be
disrespectful
okay um
the difference though is that if there's
an asian person who says i'm the new
jackie chan
and then you say okay jackie
that's not racist that's your you're not
making fun of them based on race or
ethnicity you're making fun of what they
just said and what such was the case
with the baseball player who called the
guy jackie jackie because he had called
himself jackie robinson
selena says hey matt i took a break from
your videos about eight months ago and
i'm just checking in today on all the
things that i missed and wow the
liberals have gotten worse i'm a
republican on your side and i can't
believe all this stuff i'm a former
teacher i'm watching all the things
about schools i heard about in the news
but thanks for showing all this and
opening our minds i'm in a liberal state
and everyone around me is liberal and
are okay with these kinds of things it's
clearly just the devil's work trying to
ruin this world well selena if you have
taken a break for eight months then you
may have forgotten some of the rules
around here but uh by all rights by
admitting to me that you have not
listened to the show for eight months i
mean what could you possibly be doing
for the last eight months that's more
important than this um by all by all
rights you should be banned from the
show now
but i'm feeling generous today
so as long as you promise not to leave
us again and not to leave the sweet baby
gang again i'll let you stay but thanks
for listening
well you guys know how much i love
animals uh walruses for example big
supporter there pandas not so much so of
course with uh monkey pox taking over
the headlines i've been devastated by
all the stigma being placed on our tree
frolicking friends and in that
devastation i've had precious little
time to gather the facts about monkey
pox but rather than turn to someone like
bill gates for the answers i think i'd
rather hear from an actual expert last
night dr robert malone made his return
to candace and in case you missed it he
broke down everything you need to know
about what monkey pox is and what it
isn't remember you may remember dr
malone from his interview with doc with
joe rogan his speeches also at the
anti-mandate marches or when he got
kicked off twitter for challenging the
covet narrative with you know actual
science and facts and data and those
pesky things in a time when
headline-driven panic is exploited by
big pharma and totalitarian-minded
governments more than ever it's critical
we adhere to the truth not the agenda
and the uncompromised truth of the
matter is just what dr malone and
candace get to so to help protect
yourself from monkey pox disinformation
you can watch last night's exclusive
interview by becoming a daily wire
member and right now when you head to
dailywire.com subscribe
you can get 25 off your new membership
so head to dailywire.com subscribe today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
our cancellation today deals with
something that i think is real and not a
parody but of course these days you can
never be sure um i always have in the
back of my mind the possibility that
everything happening in our culture
right now is one giant practical joke
you know i'm waiting for someone to bust
into the room at any moment point to the
hidden cameras and explain that my
entire life up to this point has been
the most elaborate prank in history
which is wishful thinking but
i have to hold on to any hope however
faint and it's better than accepting
that
this is real watch
okay this is the fatness spectrum a
small fat is a size 18 and lower 1x or
2x i'm a 4x5x i'm a size 26 sometimes
28. i am the super fat you say i'm
speaking over
just to make sure we're all on the same
page here what we just witnessed in that
video is a morbidly obese woman
responding to the charge
that she's not fat enough to have full
fat credibility in the fat community
she's accused of being a small fat as
opposed to a super fat
but she explains that according to the
fatness spectrum she actually is a super
fat and thus has the authority to speak
about fat issues
according to the fat spectrum she
provides there are four categories of
fats um small fat mid fat super fat and
infini fat
okay now infinifat
sounds like some kind of magical crystal
that a fat person might go on a quest to
obtain so they can become the greatest
the most powerful fat in the world
and that's only sort of what it means in
reality an infinite fat is someone who
wears size 6x clothing basically
if you have to go to a truck stop way
station to find out your weight um then
you're an
infinite
and you're also going to be dead very
soon that's the bad news the good news
is that for the remainder of your life
you have enormous credibility in the fat
community
and i do mean enormous
now i did uh some research into the
fatness spectrum to confirm that this is
a real thing and by real i mean a fake
thing that was really made up by real
people and to that question i can say
sadly uh yes affirmative it is in my
research the first thing i stumbled
across
was this article on the website bustle
in 2015 in which a woman
wrestles with an identity crisis after
being accused of insufficient obesity
she writes after spending a little over
two decades associating my body with
fatness
i never would have imagined that i'd be
classed as not fat or as a small fat by
anyone's standards yet when i discovered
the body positivity movement and
immersed myself into blogging it felt
like small fat was the first thing a lot
of humans saw you see within fat
acceptance bubbles on the internet
there's one body type that often
receives a bit of flack the small fat is
essentially someone who might identify
as fat or plus size but who
simultaneously fits into a smaller size
on the plus size spectrum the small fat
is likely allotted some some amount of
thin privilege with others sometimes
deeming it a body type not fat enough to
self-identify as such
now for what i understand
this is why the fat gang has an
initiation ritual where you're forced to
freebase pixie stix
and anyone who refuses is revealed to be
an undercover small fat and is then
immediately killed
fortunately teen vogue the ultimate
authority in insane bullcrap has written
a helpful explainer about the fat
spectrum
in their ask a fat girl column they
explain
these are designations on the spectrum
of fatness a set of terms created by and
for the fat community to self-identify
one's size
these fat these size categories aren't
universally agreed upon folks can
identify however they please but serve
as a general outline for where one falls
on the spectrum of fat privilege those
who fall on the smaller end of the
science spectrum are afforded more
privileges than those on the opposite
end the further you go on the larger
side of the spectrum the more likely a
person is to face discrimination
institutional sizism be denied medical
care face troubling
face trouble accessing public spaces and
more within the fat community these
designations allow for a shorthand when
sharing information for instance if i'm
in if i'm in need of a new pair of jeans
i can ask a facebook group i'm a mid-fat
looking for some new wide leg jeans any
suggestions
that way those who respond know what
general category of store i would be
able to fit in what store i would be
able to fit in
so we're going real infinite fat here i
got to look i don't know
i need to i got to go shopping and i got
to know what store i can fit in well i
fit in walmart
if you're if you're
so fat that you won't fit into walmart
then that that's not that's like i don't
know that's not infinified that's beyond
what's what's beyond infinite fat
uh
galactic fat i don't know
by the way
the categories of fatness are referred
to as categories
like ironically that's what they call
them they make that up categories
incidentally that's the term i've always
used to group fast food restaurants
together i have different categories for
fast food arby's is in the highest
ranking category because if you try to
if you tried like a super size me
experiment and ate only arby's for a
month you'd gain 600 pounds and then
your bowels would explode
that's also why arby's is the best fast
food restaurant but
also by the way in any case
what can we take away from all of this
well nothing new but there are two
things worth considering once again i
think first we see the modern leftist
obsessive and compulsive need to label
themselves
now when i was growing up it was cool to
declare yourself independent of all
labels people would say well i don't
really believe in labels
i don't do labels
and this was kind of silly but it at
least superficially encouraged people to
form distinct and independent
personalities
right it was kind of a strike against uh
conformity
of course the problem was that most of
the people that went around talking
about how they're non-conformist and
they don't believe in conformity um
those are the people that conformed the
most
but in theory again superficially it's
it's a it's a a good thing i guess to
encourage people not to conform just for
the sake of conforming but now on the
left and among the younger generations
in general
people have fled all the way to the
other extreme relentlessly inventing new
categories and categories to hide
themselves in
the labels stand in place of
identity or personality
it's like a weird sort of credentialism
but these credentials are even more
meaningless and arbitrary than the
credentials of a traditional
credentialist
second of course these are people who
along with giving up on developing real
human personalities and identities have
also given up on success improvement
self-betterment
fat acceptance like so many other types
of acceptance is a form of despair
they clamor for the highest victim
status competing with each other over
who's oppressed the most or really who
is oppressing themselves the most by
eating themselves to death the quickest
and they do this because
they don't even desire to live
successful and joyful lives
pity and affirmation is all they seek
that's why we acceptance acceptance what
a weak
meager kind of
pitiful thing that is to want out of
life that's all you want just acceptance
you don't want more than that
you're not you're not setting your your
sights any higher than that i just want
to be accepted
but this is the only pleasure that
they've ever known pity affirmation
or the only pleasure they ever want to
know
well that and eating
and they look for nothing more in life
it is sad pathetic
quite depressing
and that is why super fats small fats
mid fats infini fats and the whole
fatness spectrum
all of that today
is cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor-in-chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode a mass
shooting at an elementary school in
texas leaves several people dead
president biden's approval drops among
democrats the world health organization
considers a controversial global
pandemic treaty and the white house
addresses conflicting messages on china
and taiwan
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morningwire